Elizabeth oh this booth is in Orange
County i Elizabeth how are you hi doing
okay how are you better than I deserve
what's up well I just have a quick
question I've been applying for like a
reception job at a car dealership and
just kind of trying a lot on my first
job and I know the real moneys in sales
so my question is can I be a successful
salesperson without pushing this
financing ideology on people because I
do share your same philosophy about
always paying cash and financing well
everybody's got a definition of pushing
okay and so you you're not going to be a
successful car salesman if you only sell
people cars for cash you're going to
struggle with the sailing of cars okay
that's not pushing though I mean if
you're if you're looking at somebody
that's taking out a $500 car payment and
they make $20,000 a year
that's just immoral and I couldn't
participate in that ethically if I were
you so you know you can hold yourself to
whatever level of standard you want but
the question you've got to ask yourself
is are you bringing great harm to
someone in the transaction now I don't
believe in debt and I teach people not
to go into debt so it would be very
hypocritical for me to take credit cards
in my book store which we don't okay we
take debit cards as well and so as an
example so I'm but I have to hold to
that standard but I've got a friend that
owns a pizza joint and he takes credit
cards for pizzas and he doesn't believe
in that but somehow we're pretty sure
that buying a pizza on a credit cards
are not going to ruin somebody's life
they've got other issues if that's
ruining their life you know I'm saying
and so you know I've you know we
endorsed Churchill mortgage to take out
mortgages on houses but we want you to
pay them off as fast as you can and
that's consistent with our advice here
but we also tell people not to do
adjustable rate mortgages and you know
we asked Churchill if they come from us
if that lead comes from us right please
do not sell them an adjustable rate
mortgage you know
and but but you've got to decide we're
in there so there are car dealers that
are you know my cousin's a car dealer
he's a Chevy dealer and he does a great
job I've got several friends here in
Nashville that are car dealers and own
big big companies and you know people in
that business some of them will they'll
loan money to a dead person you know and
finish them off and then other people
are very conservative and careful and
they want the customer to not be harmed
by the transaction so that the customer
comes back to them later and buys their
next car there and if you're that person
I think you're doing that ethically if
you want to be in that business I don't
think everybody that sells cars is evil
you know but I think I think you have to
do it with a matter of I'm going to
treat other people well you know instead
of just making the trains instead just
making the transaction happen to the
detriment of the customer and that's
what you've got to think through and if
you can keep that balance then I don't I
wouldn't yell at you as your friend for
being a car salesman again I don't think
there's anything wrong with selling cars
huh I love car salesmen as a matter of
fact I bought a lot of cars so but you
know and you can make good money selling
cars right now in markets real hot you
make really good money a lot more than
being the receptionist that's for sure
so it's something to look at but if all
they're doing and they want you to make
the sale and you know and turn a blind
eye to what you feel is ethical and what
you feel is proper and what you feel is
uncaring towards people and that kind of
thing then no I wouldn't I wouldn't sell
cars for that organization but there's
other organizations that that you know
are much more reasonable and their
approach to that hey thank you for the
call this is the Dave Ramsey show